salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
aujourd'hui nous sommes à Narbonne pour
une partie 3 à Narbonne on est sur un
coin très sympa donc là on est sous une
passerelle piétonne on sait que cet
endroit a déjà été nettoyé il y a
environ 3 ans mais on est aussi sûr
qu'il va rester des choses
on est un peu à l'abri sous le pont mais
pas tellement on va essayer de faire
mieux pour pas que vous ayez trop de
bruit et on va attaquer tout de suite
avec la pêche à l'aimant
le sentir si c'est prometteur ou pas
après il va y avoir des choses récentes
pour ceux qui se le demandent on utilise
les mandars Brian de chez Maison de la
détection incapacité de 1600 kg donc de
quoi remonter du lourd pour débuter on
conseille en général d'utiliser le
terror vous avez plus d'infos sur les
modèles et un code promo en description
2 centimes pas mal
c'est quoi ça
cette boîte
[Musique]
attention raticide ne pas toucher et ne
pas déplacer
c'est quand même sympathique comme ville
Narbonne dans la dernière vidéo on avait
dit que ça puait mais c'est quand même
beau
et là je pense avoir quelque chose
lourd mais
je pense qu'il est tombé de
quelqu'un qui faisait son petit
pique-nique
dommage presque
ça peut être intéressant
tu peux faire une dédicace
allez c'est fait j'ai un truc là
il est tout neuf
oh oui une pièce
ouais
2 francs 198
0 c'est bien ouais
c'est très propre
je croyais que c'était vide
un petit Nokia
ils ont pas laissé la carte SIM par
contre me demande souvent si on tombe à
l'eau des fois c'est vrai que ça nous
arrive on vous mettra un petit bêtisier
qu'on a fait pour TikTok on vous le
mettra en YouTube short aussi
maladroit selon les interprétations
alors
vous le connaissez
sur Facebook vous regardez
ouais c'est ça ouais c'est quoi Quentin
alors il est plus beau en vidéo ouvrir
[Musique]
bonjour
d'accord ok
on va se décaler
ok d'accord
bon on s'est fait virer de la passerelle
où on était on s'est décalé un peu
on va voir ce que ça donne
de la capitainerie de Narbonne
donc on va regarder si on peut attraper
la fermeture ou enrouler les mains
autour
[Musique]
c'est rempli d'eau je sais pas comment
enlever
du coup
ça doit être une belle veste non
[Musique]
tant pis
teur
encore une fois
[Musique]
ça c'est pas aimanté
donc j'ai de la chance je l'ai eu grâce
au ferment
regarde Mathis des diamants
[Musique]
ce film n'était pas un film sur le
cyclisme malgré la présence de vélo et
voilà donc on est en fin de vidéo et on
se dit à la semaine prochaine pour une
nouvelle vidéo de pêche à aimant plus
productive je l'espère